[Music]
before we start this video I just wanted
to mention that 90% of you who watched
this channel haven't yet subscribed so
if you enjoy the content please do me a
favor and hit the subscribe button with
that being said welcome to their
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing Wizarding
children and what they do before they
start attending Hogwarts
we know that children start at Hogwarts
at age 11 so what did they do beforehand
do they attend regular muggle school to
kick things off let's have a look at why
it is that children start Hogwarts at 11
the answer to this is that the schooling
system in Harry Potter is based off of
one form of the British schooling system
in one tract of British schooling
primary school covers ages 5 to 11 where
secondary school covers ages 11 and up
because Hogwarts is modeled on a typical
secondary school with boarding it makes
perfect sense that admission was sought
at eleven years old I would imagine that
an 11 year old child though still young
would be able to more easily grasp
complicated in conceptual formats of
magic additionally by age 11 the parents
of these children would have had ample
opportunity to prepare them for magical
school it would be deeply irresponsible
to send a problem child to a magical
school and this ensures they already
have a certain level of discipline at
least in most cases Hogwarts is riddled
with all sorts of students ranging from
muggle-borns to half-bloods to pure
Bloods and while there are many purely
magical families who send their children
to Hogwarts we mustn't forget about the
muggle families Hermione for example is
the child of two muggles so their
approach to educating her may be
different than that of a pureblood
family like the Malfoy's throughout the
books in the films it appears that most
of the one carers at Hogwarts who come
from non local families have no idea
about the muggle world this implies that
they never went to any sort of muggle
school before starting at Hogwarts
they have no grasp of muggle culture
similarly muggle-borns that her new to
Hogwarts wouldn't have much of a grasp
on magical culture as their parents
wouldn't have ever had any exposure to
it
this breaks up the initial question of
what Wizarding children do before
attending a Hogwarts into two separate
questions
what do muggle-born children do before
attending Hogwarts and what do Wizarding
children do before attending Hogwarts
I'm going to be providing independent
answers to both of these but first let's
look at what JK Rowling said when she
was asked the same question they can
either go to a muggle primary school or
they're educated at home the Weasleys
were taught by mrs. Weasley while this
doesn't give us a whole lot of
information but there is more on this
topic mentioned on JK Rowling's website
they say it's the following they are as
many of you have guessed most often home
educated with very young children as you
glimpse a wizards camp before the
Quidditch World Cup in Goblet of Fire
there is the constant danger that they
will use magic
whether inadvertently or deliberately
they cannot be trusted to keep their
true abilities hidden even muggle-borns
like Harry attract a certain amount of
unwelcome attention at muggles schools
by regrowing their hair overnight and so
on bearing this information in mind we
can safely deduce that the majority of
children muggle-born or not are
home-schooled in fact all Wizarding
children that come from Wizarding
families would be homeschooled
until their time at Hogwarts the only
exception to this rule would be some
muggle-born children both miny and Harry
attended regular muggle schools before
they started to Hogwarts and the only
reason for this is that they were raised
by muggles however I would also imagine
that muggle-born children who began
exhibiting uncontrolled magical behavior
at a young age would no doubt be kept
away at home by their parents so long as
it didn't become a problem I really
don't see any reason why they wouldn't
be able to attend a record to school
because Hogwarts doesn't teach any
muggle subjects I would imagine that in
the years before they turn 11 they had
taught all of the foundational muggle
subjects this would include things like
science maths English etc by the time
they get to Hogwarts there is definitely
already an expectation that they know
how to read write and at least do some
form of math so to answer the question
posed at the beginning of the video
before starting at Hogwarts Wizarding
children mostly spend the days at home
with their families being talked to the
need-to-know subjects that will give
them a proper foundation before
embarking on their journey into
magical school environment and that's
all for this video if you enjoyed it
please hit the like button did I miss
anything if so please let me know down
in the comment section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]